the candidate for entered apprentice
stands behind the door
waiting to be summoned he's blindfolded
and there's a noose around his neck with
a length of rope trailing behind
his chest is exposed at the left breast
and his left pant leg rolled up
the door keeper wraps three times and
announces
that the candidate desires to enter and
obtain
the privileges of freemasonry
with that the candidate is escorted into
the lodge by the inner guard
the guard holds the tip of a dagger
against the candidate's bare chest
and asks if he feels anything next the
candidate
kneels before the head of the lodge the
worshipful master
and they engage in a ritual question and
answer
he's led by the rope or cable toe to an
altar with a bible or other holy book
standing with his heels together to form
a square the candidate now kneels
he places his right hand on the bible
and with his left
presses the point of a compass against
his chest
he swears to forever conceal and never
reveal
any of the secret arts parts or
points of the hidden mysteries of
freemasonry if he breaks that promise
he binds himself to having my throat cut
across
my tongue torn out my body buried in the
sands of the sea
at low tide the assembled brothers rise
and give the sign of the entered
apprentice right hand held palm
down beneath the chin with the elbows
straight out
the master asked the candidate what he
seeks
he replies the light the master strikes
his gavel
and the hood is removed now the
candidate is shown
three sacred objects the holy book the
square
and the compass the master reminds him
that he faces
terrible retribution should he ever
betray the organization's secrets
next comes instruction in the secret
hand sign or grip
and the secret word boaz the candidate
receives his masonic badge
and the symbolic tools a gavel and a
ruler
the candidate leaves to change clothes
and returns to receive the final charges
he is instructed that he must understand
the importance of god
must be law abiding must abstain from
political or religious discussion in the
lodge
and must obey the master and other
officers
he's again warned he must never reveal
any secrets of the brotherhood secrecy
if you haven't noticed is a big deal
the new brother has entered the first
grade of freemasonry
above it are two more fellow craft and
master mason
each has its ritual oath of secrecy and
prescribed
horrible punishments in regular or
blue lodge masonry that's all there is
to it
but let's take a closer look at the
brotherhood
arguably the most successful secret
society in history
we'll examine how it grew into a
worldwide presence
and how freemasonry inspired and
influenced
many other societies many freemasons
object to their order being called a
secret society
after all they don't hide their
existence they openly advertise as
evident from the signs
outside almost every american town
instead
masons prefer to be called a society
with secrets
but our definition of secret societies
selective recruitment
promise of special knowledge or status
and oaths of loyalty and secrecy
fits freemasonry perfectly remember it's
what goes on
inside the organization that's secret
the initiation's repeated demands of
secrecy make that abundantly clear
and that raises the question of how i a
non-mason
obtained those details very simple
i just looked they've long been
accessible to anybody who bothered
the illusion of secrecy is more
important than the reality
it's a common enough phenomenon that
freemasonry even has a name for nosy
outsiders
cowans cowan once met a man who
practiced
the trade without proper accreditation
but it came to signify someone who
sought to learn the secrets of
freemasonry
without being admitted to the fraternity
you might have gone through the
initiation described or one similar
there are many variations that's because
there's never been
just one freemasonry no one owns the
rights to the name
there are many variations and they don't
play by the same rules
most masonic lodges don't admit women
but some do
the usual age for admission is 21 but it
can be 25 or 18.
here's another example american masonic
lodges are mostly split between
two grand lodges or jurisdictions
the ancient free and accepted masons af
and am
and the free and accepted masons f and
am
one controls the grand lodges in 24
states the latter in
25 states there are two exceptions
south carolina which is under its own
ancient freemasons
afm and the district of columbia which
has the free and accepted masons
f-a-a-m they mutually recognize
each other as regular but different
details
yet all trace their origin to the grand
lodge of england
so how do you get four jurisdictions out
of one grand lodge
hang on we'll come back to that but you
can see why i call freemasonry
a house of many rooms another important
point
is that the origins of freemasonry are
lost in time
that gives free reign to speculation
while a lodge may consider itself
regular and another irregular that's
just a matter of opinion
ask the average mason what the lodge is
about
and the common answer will be fellowship
formally freemasonry is a system of
morality
veiled in allegory and illustrated by
symbols
consider again the initiation i
described a few moments ago
the candidate entered the lodge through
the western door
and proceeded towards the worshipable
master at the eastern end
that represents the masonic myth that
wisdom
the light comes from the east and those
in search of it
symbolically travel from west to east
the candidate was blindfolded to
symbolize his ignorance before the light
was received
his breast was exposed to prove he
wasn't a woman
his left pant leg was rolled up as
evidence that he was able-bodied
of course a single exposed limb proves
little
it's the symbolism that counts
similarly the gavel square and apron the
new mason receives are based on
actual stone mason gear
but none of them will be used to do real
work with rare exception
no one in the lodge is actually a mason
they're all just pretending to be
why then there are those terms
free and accepted free originally meant
a man who wasn't a slave or a bond
servant
and so who was able to travel from one
place to another
later it acquired the additional meaning
of someone unencumbered by any
obligations that might conflict with
masonic ones
an operative mason is someone who
actually knows and works in the trade a
real mason
accepted also called speculative masons
are men admitted to lodges without any
intention of actually laying bricks or
stones
they're symbolic masons the widely
accepted belief
is that for some inexplicable reason
stone mason guilds began accepting
non-working members over time the
accepted brethren
mostly wealthy aristocrats or tradesmen
became dominant and the real masons
dropped out
the problem with this scenario is that
no one can really say
how when or why it happened why would
rich guys want to pretend to be common
workmen
and why would guilds admit a bunch of
dilettantes
freemasonry also has been called a
course of moral instruction
aimed at building character and making
better men out of good men i.e a course
in self-improvement
this sounds similar to the late 18th
century bavarian illuminati's objective
to make men free and happy by making
them
good it's even reminiscent of the
mystical notion that
man is god in the making
according to the american esoteric
scholar and 33rd degree mason
manley p hall freemasonry is a
fraternity within a fraternity
an outer organization concealing an
inner brotherhood of the elect
that certainly sounds a little
illuminati-ish
hall adds that the visible society is a
splendid
camaraderie of free and accepted men
enjoined to devote themselves to ethical
educational
fraternal patriotic and humanitarian
concerns
the invisible society is a secret and
most august fraternity
whose members are dedicated to the
service of a mysterious
arcanum arcanorum the secret of secrets
was that the same secretive secrets that
alchemists sought
yet another masonic scholar the 19th
century american albert pike
pronounced masonry a search for the
light that
led back to the occult mysteries of the
ancient jewish tradition of kabbalah
in turn the kabbalah connected
freemasonry to hermeticism
alchemy and the anti-papal thinkers of
the middle ages
did he include among those anti-papal
thinkers the notorious knights templar
and the heretical cathars
pike argued that all divine
intelligences
gods angels and the like were divided
into
two principles of good and evil light
and darkness
to pike freemasonry was the successor or
revival of the ancient mystery cults
but he viewed regular blue lodge
freemasonry as merely
the entrance to the temple
pike's esoteric ideas weren't intended
for ordinary masons
most brethren are probably unaware of
them indeed nothing in his book
morals and dogma was sacramental or
obligatory
it was merely pike's learned opinion
still as commander of the supreme
council of the masonic scottish rite
pike wasn't without influence the
mention of the scottish rite raises the
sticky matter of masonic
higher degrees no mason is required to
go any further than freemasonry's three
craft or blue degrees entered apprentice
fellow craft
and master higher degrees are bestowed
by so-called
rites they're mostly regarded as purely
honorary or ornamental if you imagine
the craft degrees
as cub scout boy scout and eagle scout
then the higher degrees are like merit
badges and eagle scout urns to
distinguish himself
other terms for the rights and their
higher degrees are speculative or
esoteric masonry this is where the
mystical and occult
doctrines pike mentions really come into
play
over time there have been about 20
masonic rites
the best known are the scottish rite and
the york right
others include the egyptian rites of
memphis and mizrahim
there are or were french mexican
and swedenborgian rights among the
things they have in common
is that they're open only to master that
is third degree masons
but the rights aren't under any
authority or any grand lodge
thus the higher rights can pretty much
do and believe whatever they want
the number of additional degrees offered
by the rights varies widely
the scottish rite for example goes up to
33 degrees
oddly the scottish rite has no
documentable link to scotland
its origins actually traced back to
france
it also had close if hard to pin down
connections to the so-called
rite of strict observance and from that
to the raw secretions the york rite
is really a combination of three
separate masonic bodies
royal arch masonry cryptic masons
and the commandery of the knights
templar
the memphis and mizrahim right wright
outdid all others by awarding a whopping
99 degrees these included
intriguing names such as knight of the
rose cross
knight hermetic philosopher patriarch of
isis
and pontiff of the mystic city
the question of course is was this mumbo
jumbo taken seriously
or was it just for show the answer
certainly
is that it all depended on the initiate
the history of modern freemasonry begins
in 1717
in london it started with the creation
of the grand
lodge of england this grew out of four
existing lodges and steadily expanded in
england and abroad
by 1800 more than 300 affiliated lodges
existed in england alone separate grand
lodges appeared in ireland
and scotland a franchise was born
but in the 1730s the grand lodge was hit
with schism
a dispute broke out between factions
dubbed the ancients
and the moderns at issue was the
importance of rituals and associated
mystical traditions
the moderns influenced by the
rationalism of the enlightenment
wanted to chuck ritualism the ancient
purists were determined to preserve it
the underlying question was whether
freemasonry was to be a social
i.e political and philosophical order or
a mystical religious one
the same schism hit american colonial
lodges
that explains their division into free
and accepted i.e
modern and ancient free and accepted or
ancient camps the ancient and modern
rift finally healed
in 1813. the moderns yielded on the
rituals
and the ancients became more tolerant of
politics
even earlier in 1799 they were forced to
work together to avoid being
banned under the british parliament's
new unlawful
societies act fearing that secret
societies were being used to spread
french revolutionary ideas and shelter
spies
the british government proposed to quash
all societies requiring a secret oath
groups like the pro-revolutionary london
corresponding society
and the united irishmen were banned
but the freemasons received an exemption
so long as they maintained
records of their members that says a lot
about
the prestige and influence they detained
though it isn't surprising considering
that members of the royal family were
initiates
indeed freemasonry had become the secret
society of choice
for the aristocracy and rising middle
class
the cost of lodge membership including
the elaborate regalia
kept out the riffraff if freemasonry
went public in 1717
it certainly didn't start then
speculative freemasonry had been
slowly evolving for at least 300 years
the 18th century grand lodges grew out
of older ones
supposedly meeting from time immemorial
for instance in scotland there was the
kill-winning
mother lodge it claimed to have been
around since the 12th century
in york the independent grand lodge of
all
england traced its origins to 926
and a legendary convention of
stonemasons
summoned by anglo-saxon king athelstan
the 18th century lodges based their
rituals and rules on a collection of
documents called the
old charges most of which dated to the
15th century
the oldest the so-called regius or
hallowell manuscript
may go back to 1390 it mentions the
athelstan legend but also invokes the
greco-egyptian mathematician euclid
who lived around 300 bc
euclid the story goes counterfeited
geometry
and thereby invented freemasonry
of course how or why euclid did that or
what
counterfeit geometry was is left a
mystery
one of the earliest known masonic
documents is the cook manuscript
from 1450. it also mentions euclid
but brings in king solomon and pushes
things
all the way back to adam the dowling
manuscript from the mid-1500s
elaborates the connection to solomon's
temple and its
legendary master mason hiram abif
abif's death at the hands of three
unworthy apprentices
became a centerpiece in masonic
mythology
clearly no one had any real idea when
and how
freemasonry began the blank canvas
made it possible to paint in almost
anything
so why not the knights templars of the
crusades era
while a freemason templar connection
became widely accepted
there's no documentation to back it up
the possible exception is the 15th
century kirkwall scroll
from scotland it's an illustrated
tapestry in which some claim to see
templar and gnostic symbols well maybe
or maybe it's a later forgery but lack
of evidence
didn't stop american masons in 1919
they named their youth auxiliary the
demolays
in honor of jacques demille the last
templar grand master
who was burned at the stake in 1314.
the historian john robinson argues for a
genuine link between
templars and freemasons in his 1989 book
born in blood robinson focuses on the
1381
peasants revolt in england robinson
believes a shadowy
great society behind the revolt was a
conspiracy hatched by clandestine
templars
aimed at revenge against church and
crown robinson's evidence is intriguing
but ultimately thin he does raise some
interesting points
for instance while we picture medieval
mason guilds as a kind of trade union
they were really no such thing really
they were
employer associations run by master
masons
who treated their lesser brethren as
common laborers and indentured servants
thus robinson speculates the crypto
templars didn't take over genuine guilds
but formed their own pseudo-masonic
guilds as a cover
that he argues explains their obsession
with secrecy
something not typical among ordinary
masons
interestingly the knights templar had
their own internal sect of brother
masons
i.e an internal masonic guild
since most of the templar organizations
survived the suppression
unscathed presumably the brother masons
did as well
there are other examples of political
conspiracy disguised as labor
association
one is the revolutionary carbonari
or charcoal burners of early 19th
century italy and france
there were charcoal burner brotherhoods
but the carbonari
many of them freemasons co-opted the
name and terminology
as a cover for their revolutionary
conspiracies
among other things it gave you a
plausible reason to be meeting in the
woods at night
still the freemason templar connection
remains
mostly conjecture british freemasonry
would go on to become the secret society
of the establishment
in england 300 lodges grew to a thousand
by the 1860s
2000 by the 1880s and 3000 by the start
of the 20th century
hundreds more sprouted throughout the
empire
the poet laureate of british imperialism
rudyard kipling
a mason popularized the brotherhood in
his writing
look at his the man who would be king
yet the estimated 250 000 british
freemasons in 1900
were a small fraction of a population of
almost
40 million and downright insignificant
in a larger imperial population of 400
million
of course membership was heavily
concentrated at the upper end of society
men who already enjoyed some wealth and
power
for some however freemasonry wasn't
exclusive
or serious enough one such man was
arch imperialist cecil rhodes the
guiding hand behind the creation
of british south africa the de beers
diamond cartel
and the boer war
rhodes joined a masonic lodge in the
1870s because he said
he saw the wealth and power they possess
and the influence they hold
but rhodes became disillusioned with
what he referred to as the lodge's
most ridiculous and absurd rights and
thought the order was
without an object and without an end
rhodes
grand idea was to bring the whole
uncivilized world
under british rule recover the united
states
and make the anglo-saxon race one empire
so along with plotting the british
conquest of south africa's
gold and diamonds rhodes formed his own
secret organization dubbed the society
of the elect
into it he selectively recruited
statesmen financiers and industrialists
part of his scheme not incidentally was
the rhodes scholarship
designed to turn worthy americans into
right-thinking englishmen
freemasonry gave rhodes his starting
point
model and inspiration yet while kipling
and rhodes epitomized masonic loyalty to
the british empire
not all british freemasons were so
inclined
remember that house of many rooms
the grand lodge of england was always
picky about who and what it regarded as
legitimate
masonic bodies like the scottish rite
were branded irregular or clandestine
irregular freemasonry tended to attract
dissidents
both moral and political there's no
finer example than the occultist
aleister crowley
who was once branded the wickedest man
in the world
the grand lodge denied any association
with crowley
even that he was a freemason at all but
crowley boasted a bevy of masonic
degrees from french mexican and other
lodges
the esoteric organizations crowley was
associated with
like the hermetic order of the golden
dawn and the ordo
templi orientis or oto all
had masonic roots the oto for instance
was initially envisioned as a masonic
academy
that would unify masonic rights with
mystical orders
to create a unified occult freemasonry
another clandestine branch was
co-masonry
it initiated men and women alike
the practice originally started in some
18th century french lodges
it resurfaced in 1893 with the founding
of the parisian lodge
la doat uman or human right
co-masonry was later hijacked by english
occultists connected to the mystical
theosophical society
theosophy sought to combine western and
eastern mysticism
into a universal occult doctrine it
would inspire much of what we now call
the new age movement
along with a thirst for spiritual
enlightenment some theosophists nurtured
political ambitions
one of these was the english woman annie
bassant
who was largely responsible for turning
co-masonry
into an appendage of theosophy besance
politics were definitely radical
she was a socialist a militant proponent
of indian nationalism
and later flirted with communism her
freemasonry
definitely wasn't the same as rudyard
kipling's
while politics was officially forbidden
within the lodge it was practically
impossible to keep out
masonic lodges remember were selective a
single dissenting vote could blackball a
candidate
the frequent result was a lodge full of
men sharing
more or less common views and all sworn
to secrecy
connections formed inside the lodge
could take on a different dimension
outside of it simply put masonic lodges
were like petri dishes for political
conspiracy
this was most obvious in french
freemasonry and the continental lodges
it spawned and
influenced interestingly even french
freemasonry was of english origin
the first lodges were set up by british
merchants in dunkirk
in 1721. in 1733
a grand lodge de france was formed
it too was mostly english speaking and
an
extension of the london grand lodge
forty years later however the french
masons formed a new grand lodge
the grand orient de france
it was strongly influenced by the
radical ideas of the enlightenment
while english freemasonry became the
mainstay of the social order
the grand orient became an incubator of
revolutionary sentiments
it passed this radical flavor on to
lodges in italy
germany turkey and russia it's no
coincidence that the motto of the grand
orient
liberty equality and fraternity became
one of the mottos of the french
revolution
nowhere was this radical streak stronger
than in the parisian
nine sisters lodge formed in 1776
the same year as the bavarian illuminati
and the beginning of the american
revolution
american revolutionary benjamin franklin
was an initiate of the nine sisters
so too was his friend and anti-religious
french philosopher
voltaire and many other men destined to
play a part in
france's coming up evil fears that
freemasonry
nurtured and encouraged dangerous ideas
while exaggerated
weren't baseless and no one looked on
the freemasons with greater displeasure
than the papacy
in 1738 pope clement xii
issued the first edict against
freemasonry
he said that it had caused the greatest
suspicion in the mind of the faithful
and that all prudent and upright men had
judged them
depraved and perverted he condemned and
prohibited freemasonry
now and forever as clement saw it
the freemason's obsession with secrecy
condemned them
for if they were not doing evil he
reasoned they would not have so
great a hatred of the light the catholic
church
also figured in an anti-masonic brouhaha
that infected france in the 1890s
this was the so-called taxal hoax
a journalist ex-freemason and sometimes
pornographer named
josef jorgan paget decided to exploit
public anxiety over freemasonry
and satanism by combining the two
writing under the names leo taksil and
dr battai
he churned out sensational books such as
the mysteries of freemasonry and
the devil in the 19th century his pot
boiler story was that freemasonry
was run by a satanic cult the palladians
based in who'd have guessed it
charleston south carolina
and the head devil worshiper was no less
than american freemason
albert pike jogan paget even conjured a
masonic high priestess
diana vaughn who spun lurid tales of
black masses and child sacrifice for
good measure
she was supposed to be the descendant of
the 17th century
british alchemist in rosicrucian thomas
vaughn
in 1897 jogan paget further shocked
everyone especially the vatican
would he reveal that the whole thing was
a hoax and diana vaughn
a figment of his imagination
nevertheless
that didn't and hasn't stopped some from
insisting this story was true
the most important thing to take away is
that freemasonry isn't
one thing but many and it always has
been
what was true in your granddad's lodge
isn't necessarily true for others
much of this vagueness and variety stems
from the fact that freemason's origins
are lost in time so what wasn't known
was invented as ever people see what
they want to see
and believe what they want to believe
[Music]
you